on va parler un petit peu marre et ours
noirs de deux livres les plus récents
c'est à dire souvenirs pieux et archives
du nord est et jean savoir pourquoi
après vous êtes intéressés at rien et
non alexis tant d'autres vous avez
décidé de choisir vos personnages dans
votre famille
je pense que j'ai été un peu influencé
par le renoir
parce que pour le voyage prédire tâchant
d'avoir les documents nouveau une
automatique et leur très souvent j'avais
puis les noms de famille
particulièrement des noms de domaine qui
provenait documents familiaux
mais est-ce que vous avez choisi de
parler de vos ancêtres parce que vous
n'y figure et la peine avait dans ces
deux livres
oui je crois que vous êtes âgés tout au
plus de six mois 6 mai 2006 mais bon et
mais je vous ai décidé de déclasser
donner parce que ce sont vos ancêtres
parce que vos ancêtres sont des
représentants de ce qu'on peut appeler
la condition humaine la cognition
humaine
seulement il se trouve naturellement
dans des ancêtres ils sont tous
représentants de la condition humaine se
bat on n'a pas toujours les documents
dans ces cas-ci on en avait vraiment pas
mal avec bien entendu les kwasa gateways
mais qu'eux mêmes
mais ce qui est paradoxal c'est que vous
qui n'avez pas d'enfants qui n'avaient
pas de pause est mérité
vous avez une certaine manière donnez
une seconde naissance à ceux qui nous
ont précédés pour ressusciter les morts
comme disait georges romero
non je crois pas non moi je crois pas
que vous ayez ressuscité des morts je
crois que vous les avez fait naître une
deuxième fois c'est tout à fait
différent je donne un exemple de votre
si on a donné d'abord le style un peu
janséniste racing après ce style déjà
très très coloré c'était le vrai noir et
puis là je trouve que dans ces notamment
dans la chute d'une heure je trouve que
la boue
on n'est pas loin de brielles d'ailleurs
le 19e siècle
oui mais ce qu'ils voyaient encodeur pis
que dans votre cas c'est que vous avez
commencé donc par un style prêts très
maîtrisé très très très économique
et puis plus vous vieillissez plus
contraire vous allez vers un style riche
que le ccg n'ont pas cessé la
colonisation de l'espagne mais c'est
romain ne désire enfin de faire entrer
plus possible de toutes les réalités
mais ce n'est pas pris plus de plaisir à
écrire justement des ouvrages de marché
d'une heure que des ouvrages justement
plus maîtrisée comme feu comme ça du
tout les deux cas le musée n'est pas que
je suis dans un gang dans un grand état
de siège
exaltation wikio écrite mon excitation
pardon d'accroissement américain alors
quoi enfin mais tant de satisfactions à
l'herbe est alors qu'est ce que je vais
trouver une nouvelle jolie se brisa sage
le penny tude ses volets plénitude et
fable euros je voudrais savoir si dans
son jeune temps elle était fille de
berne ou servante au château si elle
aime son homme ou le fait que tu si elle
met des cierges à l'église ou peste
contre le curé ou les deux à la fois ci
elle soigne les oiseaux malades ou
claque la porte au nez des mendiants
c'est par les faits et gestes les plus
banals qu'il faut d'abord tenté de
cerner un être comme si on le crée
lyonnais à grands traits mais il serait
grossier de peynier cet inconnu ses
émotions plus subtile parce que plus pur
qui semble n'être du raffinement blâme
au sens où on suppose qu un alchimiste
raffineurs françoise a pu aimer autant
que moi la musique des ménétriers des
joueurs deviennent airs populaires
devenu aujourd'hui régal de délicats
trouvé bon un coucher de soleil rouge
sur la neige ramassez tristement un
oiselet tombé du nid en se disant que
ces grands pitié ce qu'elle a pensé
sentir égard de ces contentement et de
ses peines de ses maux physiques de la
vieillesse de la mort qui vient de ceux
qu'elle a aimé qu'ils sont en partie un
porte ni plus ni moins que ce que j'ai
pensé senti moi même
sa vie est sans doute été plus dure que
la mienne j'ai pourtant idée que c'est
couci couça elle est comme nous tous
dans l'île
three câble est inéluctable et bien moi
je dis qu'à 25 ans vous n'auriez jamais
employée aussi coup ça je ne parlais pas
de françoise bertrand arguments de
françoise leroux ready couci couça vous
voyez c'est noir ou le leu la différence
qu'on fait on relate les mois les livres
m'ont dit je hais les niveaux dit elle
ou louis est au fond assez absurde parce
que quand on dit n oublions otage d'un
doublement de parler comme si c'était
elle ou lui qui permet c'est à la
troisième personne mais c'est une
première personne déguisée
ici c'est françois ozon qui parle
comment écrivez-vous je savoir un
passage comme ça est ce que vous le
travail est beaucoup et skull
naturellement tout naturel que les
besoins ya des moments où ça ne marche
pas alors mon colis ont refait plus dix
fois dans mon papa qui lie à la conve
quelque part en fait on s'aperçoit pas
finalement fabien alors le souvenir
pieux premier volume c'est la famille
maternelle chute d'une heure c'est la
famille paternelle
on annonce un troisième volume il est
écrit chris vous n'est pas décrit n'est
même pas encore commencé parce que s'il
y voyant qu un certain succès
je n'ai pas voulu faire d'espèces
d'écriture automatique et me lancer dans
la même voie pied deux précédents j'ai
voulu réfléchir dans petit problème son
tout nouveau dans le premier volume est
le deuxième volume je ne suis pas
représentée par exemple un enfant de six
semaines dans le suivant il faudra
suivre jusqu'à sa fin quand ce ne serait
pas très raisonnable ni tripoli ne
devrait courtois de l'aviron en route
michel mon père et par conséquent nous
aurons l'histoire d'un homme qui
vieillit ne sont pas essentiellement le
fait d'avoir lee ils sont intéressants
en plus de sa passion pour la vie
jusqu'à la fin et d'autre part il y
avait des enfants
il y aura forcément moi vu que bien loin
donc et à l'orée de cette enfant il
faudra essayer de définir différents
états de l'enfance et vous il y aura les
réflexions sur les enfants c'est leur
supprimer ça me paraît difficile
c'est plus difficile
des créations vous ne connaissez sur aux
aimants sur rien en cours ou en affaires
de son pays natal invités qui
interviennent ils pourraient y voir la
timidité et pouvait avoir le faire enfin
qu'on ne se voit pas quelques grands
patrons fait le portrait au miroir
admirablement ordre on a fait toute sa
vie mais en général c'est une chose
difficile à faire et ses dangereuses
nous penser qu'on attend avec impatience
cet ouvrage se les gèle un peu parce que
j'ai une impression devait être aussi
éloigné la plupart les opinions qu'on
sait de l'enfance
ils sont mari